So today we're going to consider an
application of backward induction.
Today is going to be about
negotiation.
And the basic idea is that when two
parties are bargaining and negotiating
they often one party might make an offer
and say let's do this and then the other
party might respond with a counter offer
and it might go back and forth. So right
now the government just shut down.
That's exactly what's happening between
Trump and the Democratic Party. They
might be making countering offers and go
back and forth and see if they can
eventually reach an agreement.
So the first model we're going to
discuss
two models of negotiation. One is going
to be about
pre-trial settlements.
And the other is going to be about price
haggling.
And I think these are kind of
illustrative applications. Of course
we're not going to include all the
details of these applications. We're
going to introduce
foundational stylized models, but I
think they can capture some important
elements of of these issues. So let's
start with settlements.
So in many cases in criminal cases we
often have you know pre-trial plea
bargain uh
bargaining. And in cases we often have
the two parties
working together before the case and
trying to reach a settlement to avoid
trial.
So today let's think about civil cases.
I think that fits the
uh the model best. And in practice a lot
of civil cases never make it to trial.
The two parties reach some settlement
before the case goes to trial. What are
some reasons why cases like this often
don't go to trial? Why do we see so many
pre-trial settlements?
Uh any thoughts? Uh yeah. Both sides are
having to pay.
Legal fees, right? So legal costs are a
big
part of it and that's really what our
model today
is going to focus on. That having a
drawn-out trial is very costly. Did you
have the same idea or any other
same idea? Anyone else? Any other
reasons?
Um it could be legal costs. It could
just be the cost of delay which is
similar but slightly different, right?
It could be that even aside from paying
the lawyers
you know if we're going to be stuck in
court for so long and it's going to
delay
um you know our productive activity that
may be costly.
Um another big one could be risk
aversion.
Right? This is not going to be in our
model today, but it might be that I
think that if we go to court there's a
chance I win tons of money. There's a
chance I don't win anything. So I'd
rather accept a settlement where I win
some small intermediate amount of money
with certainty.
So risk aversion and I should be clear
here over monetary payouts.
I think this is also true in criminal
cases where someone might think well
there's a chance I get a life sentence.
I'd rather accept a plea bargain where
I'm certain to go to prison for 5 years
rather than have a risk that I serve a
life sentence.
And then maybe one final one that we
often see is about kind of privacy
and maybe embarrassing
information coming out
or potentially trade secrets being
revealed at trial.
There are some provisions to try to
prevent this, but I think they're still
some some risk of this.
So today we're going to introduce a
formal model that can try to make some
predictions about um what kind of
settlements we'll see and how long
negotiations will last. Of course this
model isn't going to capture everything,
but it's going to be a good starting
point for today. So in our model we're
going to have two parties
we call the plaintiff and the defendant.
So the plaintiff is the party that's
suing someone else. So the plaintiff
feels that they've been wronged and
they're seeking a monetary settlement.
The defendant has been accused of
wronging someone and they're being
potentially asked to pay a monetary
settlement. So let's be clear at the end
there's going to be if they reach some
settlement
that's an amount of money that's going
to go from the defendant to the
plaintiff, right?
So from maybe I'll just write it with
arrows
D to P.
So just to make sure we're on the same
page the defendant is hoping to pay out
a very small settlement. The defendant
doesn't want to have to pay a big fine
or big punishment to the plaintiff.
The plaintiff is seeking a very large
settlement, right? Cuz they want to get
paid out as much as possible.
And in this case we're going to make a
few simplifying assumptions. One of them
is that there's no uncertainty about the
outcome of a trial.
Why are we doing this? Well we want to
isolate the effect of legal costs.
Uh in this model we're not going to
worry about risk aversion and the
potential uncertainties that come with
trial. So what we're going to assume
here to make things simple is that if
they go to trial
the settlement amount
is known to be will definitely be J and
we'll use J to indicate judge. This is
what the judge decides. So both parties
know if we go to trial
the amount that's going to be agreed
upon. So here we're not thinking you
might imagine the judge deciding whether
you know the plaintiff whether the
defendant did anything wrong at all.
Here we're we're imagining that yeah the
defendant has certainly done something
wrong. The question is only how much
they have to pay.
And here the assumption is that if they
go to court the amount of the settlement
will be some fixed amount J.
And then we need to specify what the
costs of going to court are. So maybe
the trial costs
are going to be
CP
for the plaintiff
and CD for the defendant. And I think in
the notes they use capital letters, but
I find at the board it's hard to know
what's capital and lower case. So I'll
just use a hat to indicate the costs um
if we go to trial.
But then each period that we negotiate
before the trial also has costs, right?
You don't just pay the lawyers when you
go to trial. If you want to try to reach
a settlement that in itself is costly.
So we're also going to assume that there
are
kind of per period
and that'll be clear when I describe the
periods
per period negotiation or pre-trial
negotiation costs.
And these are just going to be CP
and CD without hats. So each period that
we negotiate for the plaintiff has to
pay a cost of CP to their lawyers and
the defendant pays a cost CD to their
lawyers.
So now let's describe the alternating
offer structure of this game. This is a
very common
format that we see in reality. You make
some offer the other side
will say either say it's acceptable or
they might reject your offer and then
come back with a counter offer that's
more favorable to them.
So we're going to imagine that uh
we have time going we have period one
zero period one period two period three
all the way up to let's say two n minus
one
two n
minus one and then two n.
And what we'll imagine is that it's
known that the set of the date of the
trial is set. So this is the trial.
So we know
that the trial is going to occur in
period two n and if we go to trial
when I say it will occur what I mean is
if we don't reach a settlement before
then then the trial occurs and we know
what's going to happen. The settlement
is going to be J and we're going to have
to pay all these legal costs.
But in anticipation of the trial what
we're imagining is there's time to have
kind of n rounds
or two n minus two n periods but n total
rounds of alternating offers.
So what we imagine is
in the
first period the plaintiff is going to
be the one who's going to propose.
So it's a little confusing P is for
plaintiff you're not proposer, but the
plaintiff
um
maybe I'll say offers.
I'll call this S0.
So in period zero they're going to say
look
let's just settle and the amount that
you're going to have to pay me I'm the
plaintiff you're the defendant the
amount that you're going to have to pay
me is S0.
Do you want to accept this or not?
And if it's accepted then you pay me
this amount we're done and if it's
rejected we continue. So then the
defendant can choose
either to accept
or reject.
And if the defendant accepts this offer
well now we're done.
The defendant pays S0 we never go to
court the game is over.
But if they reject this offer well
they're not just going to reject they're
going to come back tomorrow and propose
a counter offer.
So in the next period the defendant is
going to make an offer
and now I'll call that offer they can
make any offer they want S1.
Right? And this is going to say
let's settle now and I'll pay you S1
dollars if you accept it.
And again now it's the plaintiff's turn
who's going to say
who's going to choose
either to accept
or reject.
And we can see how this is going to keep
going
until
let's see in even periods the plaintiff
is making the offers.
So two n minus
If we get to this point would make an
offer
let's say S 2N - 2. And again, in this
case, the defendant is going to choose
to accept or reject.
If it's rejected, we move here. Now,
it's the defendant's turn. They're going
to make this last offer
S 2N - 1
and the plaintiff is going to choose
whether to accept or reject that offer.
And this is only and only in this last
period I think different, right? So, in
this last period, if the offer is
accepted, great, it's over as before,
but if it's rejected, well, now the
trial is here. So, instead of going to
one more round of negotiation, we just
go to trial and we see what the outcomes
are going to be.
So,
just so we understand the costs, the
CP hat and CD hat costs, the trial
costs, are only realized if we actually
go to trial.
Whereas, the
per period negotiation costs are
realized in every period until we reach
a settlement.
So,
here we have CP CD, here we have CP CD,
and so on.
So, just so we understand, if we were to
settle
in this period zero, we would have only
had to negotiate for exactly one period.
So, we'd each bear these costs only
once. But if we settled in say the third
period, period three, well, it's tricky,
right? Cuz we started at zero. So, if we
settle here, then we've had to negotiate
1 2 3 4 periods, and that means we'll
each have to pay four times our per
period uh negotiation costs.
If we were to all the way go to trial,
we're going to have to pay our trial
costs and well, we we've negotiated each
of these periods. So, we'll each have to
pay 2N for the 2N negotiation periods
times our per period negotiation costs
plus
the cost of going to trial.
So, this is the game.
And now, what we'd like to do is
analyze this game using uh backward
induction.
Any questions on the
setup of the game?
So, let's first just recall
what backward induction is going to
deliver for us.
So, we're going to apply backward
induction.
What this is going to give us is a
special
Nash equilibrium.
Remember,
first we have to think, are we allowed
to apply backward induction?
Well, backward induction only can be
applied to games with extensive form
games
with perfect information.
And here, we have perfect information
cuz there's no point in the negotiation
where someone doesn't know what someone
else did previously, right? Everything
is observed in this game. So, we're
allowed to apply backward induction.
The problem with games like this is that
there are many many Nash equilibria that
may involve
non-credible threats.
So, backward induction is going to give
us this very special Nash equilibrium,
and sometimes the the term we use, you
know, maybe another way of saying
special is it's going to be a Nash
equilibrium, but it's also going to have
this property that's often called
sequential optimality.
Remember, our key observation from last
class was that Nash equilibrium by
itself doesn't necessarily imply
sequential optimality. That is, it may
be under some Nash equilibria that
players are behaving suboptimally
at contingencies that are not reached.
And sequential optimality imposes the
stronger condition that we have optimal
play
at every contingency.
Particular, even those contingencies
that are not reached.
So, Nash equilibrium is already going to
take care of the contingencies that we
do reach. Nash equilibrium is already
going to require optimal play at those
contingencies,
but Nash equilibrium doesn't actually
impose much many constraints on these
unreached contingencies. And what
sequential optimality does or requires
is that players are playing optimal even
there.
Because if players were not playing
optimal
at some contingency, that would capture
what we think of as a non-credible
threat. That would mean a player was
threatening to behave in such a way that
would not be optimal for them or
credible for them to follow through on
if that contingency were actually
reached.
Now, a key thing to keep in mind here is
that what backward induction gives us is
a Nash equilibrium. So, it's going to
give us a strategy profile. So, often,
what when people analyze a game like
this, it's tempting to say, "Oh, the
answer is
we settle in period five and this is the
amount of payments."
That's an outcome of the game, but
that's not a complete description of the
strategies, right? So, a Nash
equilibrium is going to have to specify
the players' complete contingent plans
throughout the game. And that means that
the strategies in games like this are
much much more complicated than the
actual outcome that's reached, which
might just be we settle for this amount
in this period.
Okay, so let's get into it. It's
backward induction, so we're going to
work backwards,
uh not surprisingly, and let's start
with, well,
you might say we're working backwards,
let's start in period 2N - 1.
But actually, even within period 2N - 1,
we have sequential moves, right? First,
the defendant makes an offer and then
the proposer responds.
So, if you want to work backwards, we're
actually going to split this last period
up into two and we're going to work in
the second part of the last period.
So, we're going to say, suppose we're in
period
2N
- 1.
And the contingency we're at as the
plaintiff is that we're facing some
offer
from the defendant. So, let's
so, given some offer
S 2N - 1,
this is an offer by the defendant.
The proposer has two choices.
They can either
accept the offer
or they can reject the offer.
I should point out here that I'm being a
little sloppy.
I'm saying, suppose the proposer
receives an offer of S 2N - 1.
But technically, this doesn't specify
the full contingency. What would I need
to specify if I wanted to say
if I were to write out this whole game
tree and I want to figure out where I am
in the game tree, what is this
contingency going to specify within the
tree?
It's not just enough to specify
the offer in the last period. I can
Yeah. I need to know about everyone
before.
Everything that happened before, right?
Because we know in a tree, when we're at
a node in the tree, that node tells us
the entire path through the tree. So,
technically, a contingency would be
something like
the plaintiff made this offer in the
zeroth period and it was rejected.
The defendant made this offer in the
next period, it was rejected. The
plaintiff made this offer, it was
rejected, and so on.
But what I implicitly mean here is
there's a lot of different
contingencies, but the incentives of the
plaintiff are going to be the same at
all the contingencies where this is the
offer that's made. So, I'm basically
grouping all the contingencies in my
head and kind of reasoning about all of
them together at the same time. Because
at this point, if you're offering me S
2N - 1,
I don't really care what you offered me
three periods ago, that's not on the
table, so it's not relevant to my
optimal decision. But if I wanted to be
really precise, I could, in principle,
behave differently at different
contingencies.
Okay. So, now let's carefully write down
my payoffs.
If I accept this offer as the plaintiff,
what are my payoffs going to be? My
total payoffs, taking into account the
settlement, my legal costs, all these
things.
Yeah. Should I just say S 2N - uh 1?
Okay. Um minus uh CP times 2N minus 2.
Uh yeah, I think 2N - 1 because we
started at zero.
Um but
let's let's go over it. Yeah.
>> That would be then 2N minus 2 is a 2N
minus Oh, yeah, 2N minus 1. Yeah. Uh so,
it'll be So, I'll I'll just write it and
then I'll explain, but yeah, it's easy
it's and I might get confused with some
of these fence post issues, but I think
it's going to be
CP times
2N.
Uh
Why is this? Well, we're in period N
minus 1.
If I accept the offer,
then I'm going to get a settlement of S
2N - 1,
but I've also had to pay my legal fees.
I'm the plaintiff, so my legal fees are
CP per period, and we negotiated in
period zero, in period one, in period
two, in period three, all the way up to
period 2N - 1. You might say that's 2N -
1 periods, but remember, we started at
zero. So, we actually have 2N periods
of uh
negotiation costs.
And then, what if I reject the offer?
What's going to happen?
Yeah. J minus CP hat.
Right? And we can't forget I've already
I mean, it's sort of a sunk cost, but
then we have this as well, right? So,
it's going to be J minus CP hat minus CP
times 2N.
What does this mean? Well, if I reject
the offer,
we're going to go to court.
I get a judgment of J as the plaintiff.
I have to additionally pay all the court
costs and then I have all these costs
from before. But, I think what people
are kind of jumping ahead is these don't
really matter, right? So, we can sort of
circle these.
At this point, these are what are called
sunk costs, right? I've already paid all
of these costs. So, in my decision today
of whether to accept or reject, these
aren't actually going to have any
bearing on my choice because I pay them
either way. I've already paid them. I've
already paid the lawyers. The only
choice I really have is am I going to
pay this additional
um trial fee CP hat.
Um
Great.
So, now if we compare
these two payouts,
when should the plaintiff accept the
offer? What kind of offers should the
plaintiff accept?
Well, intuitively, they're the
plaintiff. They want more money. So, we
always think the plaintiff should accept
Let's just write this down here. It's
always going to take this form that
they're going to accept
if and only if
maybe I'll say use arrows. If and only
if S2N
- 1
is greater than or equal to some
threshold. Let me write denote this
threshold as S2N - 1 star.
And this is just We know this is
generally how things are, right? If
you're the plaintiff, this is how much
you get paid.
Getting offered more money is always
better. So, it makes sense that you're
going to accept if the offer is high
enough,
and you're going to reject if the offer
is too low. The question is what is this
critical threshold? What's the amount
that you have to offer me as the
plaintiff for me to accept your offer?
Yeah. J minus CP hat. Right.
J minus CP hat.
And you might say, well, we have to be a
little careful if the offer is exactly
equal to this, maybe I'll accept, maybe
I won't. We're going to make the
convention that when indifferent, I
always accept, and this is what we sort
of have to do to make sure that
equilibria exists.
But, notice what's interesting here.
What is the plaintiff willing to accept?
They're willing to accept some offers
that are strictly less than the amount
that they would get in court.
So, what does this reflect? This
reflects the cost of going to court. If
you say, "Look, I'm not going to pay you
as much as you'll get in court. I'll pay
you a bit less, but it's still worth it
for you because if you accept my lowball
offer, you get to avoid the cost of
going to court."
So, we can see the higher that CP hat
is,
the weaker the bargaining position of
the plaintiff.
The more the lower the offer that
they're going to be willing to accept
because they really don't want to go to
court and pay this enormous fee.
Okay?
So, now we go back one step earlier.
We're still in period 2 and minus 1, but
now let's think about the
defendant's
choice.
Now, the question is how much should
they offer?
Anticipating that the plaintiff will
accept their offer
exactly under these conditions.
Well, intuitively, they want to make the
smallest offer
that will be accepted. They want to pay
the least amount that they have to. So,
there it's going to be optimal for them
to choose S2N - 1 equals S2N - 1 star.
They could offer to pay
strictly more than this. That'll still
be accepted, but that's worse for them
because they don't want to pay out very
much.
I think it's a little tricky though
because they might also want their offer
to get rejected. So, we still have to be
a little careful. Let's see, what if the
offer gets rejected?
We're claiming that they want to make an
offer that'll be accepted, but we
actually have to see what happens if it
gets rejected. Um
It turns out if it gets rejected, and
let's just sort of work this through,
this will be accepted, and then they
will get
minus
S2
Yeah. S2N - 1 star minus
CD2N.
And what if they were to make some
different offer that were rejected?
What would their
payout
What would their payout be?
Yeah. Uh minus J minus C times 2N
minus uh
CP hat.
Exactly. So, if they make an offer
that's rejected, then they're going to
go to court,
and that means they're going to lose J.
They're going to lose C
D hat,
and they're going to lose CD2N.
But, this is clearly worse because if
they go to court, they have to pay more.
They pay J rather than J minus CP hat,
and they have to pay the costs of court.
So, this is kind of extra bad.
So, they
pay more,
and they pay the court costs.
And we'll sort of see throughout that
um it's never really going to be optimal
for people to make offers that are going
to be rejected. It's always going to uh
it's always just going to make things
worse for them.
So, indeed, this is going to be the best
choice for CD.
All right. Now, let's try to go
one step back
and see what's going to happen
in
period 2 and minus 2. Maybe I'll come
back over here.
And then hopefully we'll be able to see
a pattern.
So, now let's go to period
2N
minus 2.
And
our conjecture is that
the
I have to do it right here. The
defendant
is going to accept
an offer of S2N - 2
if and only if
S2N - 2 Well, let's see. I'm the
defendant now.
So, I'm willing to accept low offers,
right? The plaintiff was willing to
accept high offers.
The defendant is willing to accept low
offers.
So, there's going to be some threshold
S2N - 2 star such that the play the
defendant will accept if they're offered
to pay a small enough amount.
Is there any show here? Yeah. Yeah, I
have a question. Yes. Uh basically, the
comparison between the uh getting an
offer and getting rejected. So, getting
an offer, they have to pay S2N - 1 star,
which is J minus CP versus
oh, J plus
Yeah, so we have to be careful with the
minuses. So, what's this is going to be
uh minus J
plus
CP hat. So, doesn't it depend on like
how CP hat is? It doesn't, and that's
why And this is what I meant about it's
kind of doubly bad for them. Because if
their offer's rejected, um
they're going to have to pay the full
settlement J in court. So, they're going
to uh the defendant will have to pay
more in court, and on top of that,
they'll have to pay their legal fees.
So, the difference between these two is
actually the sum of CP hat and CD hat.
It's not about the the relationship
between them. Yeah. Good point. So, just
to be clear what the argument is, the
argument is
I could make some offer that's rejected.
If it's rejected, the amount that I
offer doesn't matter. All that matters
is it's rejected, and we've shown that
that's worse than making this offer.
The alternative is I could make an offer
that will be accepted, but to make an
offer that will be accepted, I'd have to
offer even more than this, and that
would is certainly worse for me. So, the
best thing I can do is offer the
smallest amount that will be accepted.
Okay.
So, now
what our sort of guess
is that the structure in period N minus
2 is going to 2N minus 2 is going to be
something like this.
The defendant is going to have some
threshold where they're going to say,
"Look, I'll accept the offer if and only
if it's small enough. If and only if
it's below some threshold."
And then let's think about the
plaintiff's problem. We could go through
the algebra to check, but you can see
that the plaintiff wants to make
wants the offer to be the settlement to
be as large as possible.
But, if it's too large, it won't be
accepted.
So, they want to make the largest demand
the largest settlement that will be
accepted, and that's precisely S2N - 2
star.
So, all we have to do is find this
number, and that's sort of how these
games reduce. At each stage, one side is
going to accept if and only if the offer
is above or below some threshold, and
the game the name of the game is finding
these thresholds.
So, let's see. Well,
let's try to understand
what this threshold needs to be
by let's
let's going up here.
So, the threshold needs to be such that
they're indifferent
between accepting this offer and
rejecting. That's That has to be true at
a threshold because if they weren't
indifferent, there's no way that could
be the threshold.
So, if they
accept this offer,
what are they going to get?
They're the defendant, so they have to
pay it. So, they're going to get minus S
2N - 2 star
minus all the legal fees that they have.
So, that's we minus CD times 2N - 1.
So, now we're one period earlier. So, if
we accept a settlement here, we don't
have to pay legal fees in the last
period.
And this is how much uh we're going to
have to pay, so we have a negative sign
in front.
What happens if we reject this offer?
Well, this is where backward induction
comes into play. Because in general, I
don't know what happens, what my payoff
is from rejecting this offer, because it
depends on what's then offered to me in
the next period. But because we've
already used backward induction the next
period, we know what's going to happen
in the next period. In the next period,
the plaintiff is going to offer exactly
this,
and then it's going to be optimal for me
as the defendant to accept it.
So, if I wait till the next period,
I'm going to have to pay negative S 2N
minus 1 star
minus what are my legal fees if I accept
this in the next period?
Yeah.
times 2N, right? Because if I reject
today and wait till tomorrow, I have one
more period of negotiation, so that
means it's going to be CD times 2N.
And now we sort of see the pattern. What
are we going to find?
We're going to find that S 2N minus 2
star
equals
S 2N
minus 1 star
plus
CD.
That's right.
The
Yes, I think that's right.
Which we can do our math over here.
And this is
J
minus CP hat plus CD.
Why is it a plus? We could try to go
through the algebra.
Um
but
can we just reason through this why we
get a plus CD here?
Why am I as the defendant willing to
accept a settlement that's strictly
higher than the settlement I would get
tomorrow?
Yeah. Um because you're not going to
tomorrow, so you're not going to have
the CD from the next period, so you're
adding it back. Exactly right. So, what
am I saying? I'm saying, "Look, I can
wait till tomorrow, and then I have to
pay you this much. That's going to be
the outcome of negotiation tomorrow.
But if I pay you an amount today, I save
one unit of negotiation costs. So, I'm
actually willing to pay more today. I'm
willing to get a worse offer today
because I'm saving the legal costs of
going tomorrow."
And you can see how these kind of
enter differently, right? The plaintiff
was also willing to accept a worse offer
to save on legal costs. But for the
plaintiff, a worse offer is a smaller
settlement, cuz they get paid the
settlement. For the defendant, they're
willing to accept a worse offer to save
on legal fees, but for them a worse
offer means paying more. So, if I'm the
defendant, I'm basically saying, "Look,
I'll pay you off to save me the money of
going to court."
And the plaintiff is saying, uh "You
better pay me a lot."
Um
All right, sorry. I'll accept not paying
you very much in order to avoid going to
court.
I'll accept you not paying me very much
to avoid going to court.
Okay.
So, now I think we can keep doing this
all day, but I think we're going to see
a pattern emerge, so let's see if we can
guess what the pattern's going to be
for these thresholds.
So, it's always easy to get get off by
one. Let's see
I've done it right. Let's look at
the
We started in an odd period, so we have
the odd periods and the even periods.
In the
odd periods, the
defendant
is going to propose
S, let's say the odd period is
2N
minus 2K minus 1.
And in the even period, it's 2N
minus 2K.
And here we're going to have K
greater than or equal to
1.
So, here
let's just write down the formula and
then check that we have it right. I
think the defendant is going to propose
J
minus
CP hat
plus
K minus 1
of
CD
minus CP.
And here, I think
the plaintiff
is going to propose
Let's check if I did this right.
So, let's first try
K equals 1.
If K equals 1, we're in period 2N minus
1, so we better get J minus CP hat.
And that's exactly what we get.
If K equals
uh
1 down here, we're in 2N minus 2,
and we better get J minus CP hat plus
CD. So, I think that
um that looks correct.
And then
the Let's just check what's happening
here.
accepts
if and only if
And here, the defendant accepts
if and only if Well, in these periods,
they're going to accept if and only if
Well, the plaintiff is the one who uh
receives the money, so they're only
going to accept it if it's large enough
if and only if the settlement is greater
than or equal to this number here.
And the defendant is going to accept if
and only if F is less than or equal to
this number here.
So, the defendant is making is proposing
the smallest settlement amount that will
be accepted because they like low
settlement amounts.
And here, the plaintiff is proposing the
largest settlement amount that will be
accepted because they like to receive
high settlements.
Okay, so this is the strategies.
We specified all the strategies at every
contingency.
But let's now compute what actually
happens,
right? The strategies say under in every
contingency, what do people do? But what
actually
happens in this big game? We made it
really complicated, but what happens is
actually going to be
pretty simple.
You want to see what
is actually going to happen?
So, when are they going to settle?
Are they going to settle?
Do we go to trial? What happens? We have
the strategy here, we just have to
figure out
what's actually going to be done.
Well, let's start in the first period,
and let's go through it.
In period zero,
what is going to happen? Well, period
zero means K equals N.
So, the plaintiff is going to propose
this settlement amount. J minus CP hat
plus N minus 1 times this plus CD.
And then
the defendant is going to accept it.
So, that's it.
So, the outcome is actually very simple.
The outcome is we settle
in period zero
for this amount down here.
Yeah, this looks right. I'm just making
sure I'm not off by one index.
So, can we
try to interpret this amount?
How does this amount compare to J?
Well,
we see that the settlement is going to
be smaller if CP hat is really big.
So,
the settlement is going to tend to be
smaller
if CP hat
is big.
And it's going to tend to be
bigger if CD minus CP is large, right?
Do we have intuition for this?
Well, let's see. If CD minus CP is
large,
that means the defendant has higher
negotiation costs.
And that means the defendant is at a
strategic disadvantage.
The fact that they have high
negotiation costs means the other side
can drive a hard bargain.
And because of that, the defendant is
going to have to end up paying a larger
settlement.
Notice that it's not only big if CD
minus P CP is big, but it also depends
on how far away the trial is.
So, if the trial is really far away,
then
the defendant is really in trouble
because the defendant's higher legal
fees per period could really add up over
the many, many periods that go on going
to trial.
On the other hand, if the plaintiff's
cost of going to trial is really, really
high,
then the settlement is going to be
smaller.
Because this is going to advantage the
defendant.
Uh they're not going to have to pay out
as much if they can drive a hard bargain
to the plaintiff in the last period.
But here's one kind of puzzle. What
happened to CD hat?
It doesn't appear at all. So, why why
does it not depend at all
on
CD hat?
Yeah. You said that
the defendant is always going to accept
in the last period, so the cost of trial
is never realized.
Um
that's right, but you know, we also
never get to the fifth period.
But the the costs that we would incur if
we get to the fifth period also show up.
So, I think I think that's part part of
the way there. Yeah.
Because the defendant is the last
proposer, so they can base it on what
the plaintiff will accept.
Um exactly right. So, if we actually
change the timing here, and this is one
issue with these bargaining games, is
that sometimes the details matter a lot.
If we had an odd number of periods
before trial, this would kind of flip,
and we would care about CD hat, not CP
hat.
And the reason is that
the defendant is the one able to exploit
the plaintiff's cost of trial because
the defendant gets to make the last
offer before trial.
So, because the defendant is the one who
makes the last offer before trial, the
defendant can say, "You better give me a
really good deal, otherwise we're going
to have to pay this high cost to go to
trial."
It's interesting though. I mean, the
defendant also pays a high cost to go to
trial.
But uh they're able to exploit the
rationality of the plaintiff and sort of
make them an offer that they're going to
have to accept. Uh and therefore take
advantage of their bargaining power.
Um
Great.
So, I guess a few takeaways, this model
suggests that we shouldn't have drawn
out negotiations, that the settlement
should end right away, but notice that
the potential length of the negotiation
affects the outcome. So, even though we
settle in the very first period, the
potential to have a very long drawn out
negotiation drives the amount that we
settle for in this first period.
One final thing, if on the exam you're
asked about this,
the strategy is not we settle in the
first period, the strategy is this
really complicated thing, the outcome is
that we settle in the first period.
Now, in reality, we often see long drawn
out negotiations. So, I think it's often
very helpful in economic models to say
what's missing.
Why is it that in reality, let's say
Trump and the Democrats, I think they're
going to be negotiating for a pretty
long time, would be my guess.
Uh
that's completely inconsistent with the
prediction of this model. So, what do
you think is missing in this model uh
that explains why everything ends in the
first period? Yeah. Uncertainty about
what J actually is. Exactly. An
uncertainty about the preferences of the
other side, what they're willing to
accept. Here, we all know exactly what
the other side is is going to accept,
and we can uh push them just to the
brink of acceptance in every round, and
therefore there's no reason for things
to evolve over time.
The reason that we often have delay and
impasses in bargaining is that we don't
know
what the other side is willing to
accept, and we might want to make them a
really bad deal early on
uh in case on the off chance that they
end up uh not being who we thought they
were.
Uh and we'll see later in the course
models of bargaining with incomplete
information or uncertainty about the
opponent's preferences, and that will
exactly lead to delayed bargaining,
right? Imagine you were negotiating with
someone, and you didn't know if they
were a tough negotiator or a soft
negotiator. You might want to make a
really ridiculous offer in the first
period that only the soft negotiator
would accept, but that you know the hard
negotiator would not accept, and then
move to the next period and change your
strategy. So, uh that's kind of the the
basic idea of what goes goes on when you
have incomplete information about the
other players.
Okay, let's now move to
uh the second
bargaining situation today, which is
going to be
haggling over the price.
So, now we're going to imagine that we
have um
call this price haggling.
Let's suppose that we have a seller
and a buyer.
And the
seller just wants to get paid.
Uh they're negotiating over the price of
some item.
So, if they trade at price P,
then the seller, their utility is going
to be the price P that they get.
The buyer's utility is going to be V
minus P.
So, that means P is the price,
and V is the buyer's value for the good.
So, notice here we're assuming that it
doesn't cost anything for the seller to
produce the good. That's a simplifying
assumption. It's already been produced,
maybe they can't resell it to anyone
else. They're just stuck with it. So,
the seller values the good at zero.
They're thinking of selling it to the
buyer who buy who values it at V,
and they're trying to haggle over what
the price should be.
So, first of all, let's just kind of
make sure we understand
what's a reasonable range of what the
price can be. So, I think there's some
prices that we can rule out, right? How
how low could the price be?
What's the lowest it could kind of
possibly be?
Well, actually, it could be pretty low.
I think it could go all the way down to
zero in principle, right? It's certainly
not going to be less than zero though.
Cuz if it was less than zero, well, the
seller would never accept being paid a
negative price.
What about the highest price that we
would expect to see here?
Yeah.
V. It certainly can't be more than V
because the buyer would never accept a
price above V.
So, we can kind of
at first pass, just by basic individual
rationality uh
concerns, see that the price is going to
be somewhere between zero and V, and
both players are going to get some
non-negative utility. But the question
is, where is it between zero and V? The
seller would love it to be very close to
V,
uh and basically uh leave the buyer with
nothing and charge them their full
valuation for the good. The buyer would
love to pay a price uh that's really,
really low so that they can get all the
value from the good. And we're going to
try to make some predictions about where
within this interval the price can be.
Notice this is kind of a common
situation that we generally only accept
expect that goods are going to be
exchanged when the seller values the
good more than the buyer.
And we generally expect the price to be
somewhere between uh sorry, when the
seller values the good less than the
buyer, and we expect the price to be
somewhere between what the seller values
it at and what the buyer values it at.
And here, what the seller values it at
is zero.
You can think of this as the seller's
value,
and this is the buyer's value.
So, the buyer does value it more. That's
why it makes sense for them to buy it,
but where the price lies between these
two valuations is is the name of the
game. That's what we're trying to figure
out.
Now, what we're also going to imagine it
is that there's a cost of delay,
but we're going to model the cost of
delay a bit differently.
Here, we model the cost of delay as an
additive cost. Each period we uh had to
pay a lawyer some, you know, daily fee,
and and that had a cost. Here, we're
going to say the cost of delay, we're
going to use what's called uh
discounting.
So, the idea is that
if we trade in period T,
then the utilities we actually get would
be delta
P for the seller,
and delta V minus P for the buyer
to the T,
where
delta
is between zero and one.
So, here, you may have seen this in
other economics courses, delta is called
our discount factor.
And what this says is each period we
wait, our utilities get multiplied by
this number delta, which is less than
one, and therefore they get smaller.
So, if T is really, really big, then the
seller doesn't get the full utility from
the price, they get that times delta to
the T because each period they have to
wait beyond the zeroth period, they
incur this multiplicative uh discount of
delta, and similarly for the buyer. They
incur this multiplicative discount of
delta.
So, let's understand if delta is very
close to one,
then that would indicate the players are
uh quite patient.
Because as time passes, delta to the T
doesn't get smaller that quickly if
delta is very close to one.
If delta is very close to zero, the
players are extremely impatient.
And as time passes, their uh
their utility is going to drop a lot and
therefore the cost of delay becomes very
high.
So, maybe I'll
You can say this in a few ways.
You might say low delta
is another way of saying the players are
impatient.
Or another way of saying that is the
cost of delay is high.
AND THEN CONVERSELY, IF WE HAVE HIGH
DELTA, THE players are very patient and
the cost of delay is not very high.
>> [snorts]
>> Um sometimes we think of delta as being
related to the interest rate. So, in a
financial context, the cost of delay
with money is the interest rate that you
could have gotten by putting that money
in a bank account or getting some return
in in equities.
Okay. And now we're going to
assume that time
proceeds just as before.
So, I think this is kind of exactly what
you see if you go to a market,
especially in developing countries and
there aren't posted prices. You as the
buyer go up and you say I'm willing to
pay you this and they say, "Oh, no. You
need to pay me this much." And then you
counter offer and you go back and forth,
right? So,
and even in developed countries, this
certainly happens if we're negotiating
on some big deal, right? It doesn't
happen at Starbucks. You're probably not
going to be able to negotiate with the
price of your coffee, but if you're
getting hired at a firm or if you're
making a merger, people do negotiate all
the time on prices.
So, 2n - 2, 2n - 1, and then 2n.
And the order I think we're going to
assume is the seller makes the first
offer.
So, here the seller offers
a price P0. So, instead of offering a
settlement amount, they're offering a
price. The buyer can either
accept or reject.
If it's accepted, we're done. If it's
rejected, now the buyer gets to make a
counter offer of P1 and the seller can
accept reject.
And we're going to go on like this
uh all the way up to seller making an
offer P2n - 2,
buyer making an offer P2n - 1.
And then we're going to assume it at
period 2n, kind of the world ends or it
just That's it. We both get zero.
So, if we wait this long,
we get payoffs
of 0 0.
Um this seems like a strange assumption.
The The real reason is that we don't
quite have the tools to analyze what
happens if it could go on indefinitely,
uh but it turns out that if you take n
to be really really big, the predictions
that we'll get will be very similar to
the predictions if there's an indefinite
end date. So, as I tell the story of
like the the tourists get off the tour
bus at the at the market and the tour
bus is leaving in 2n periods and this is
the last chance for them to make a
trade, but you know, are there really or
you know, people say the ice cream
melts, but uh yeah, I don't know how
compelling this exact end date is uh and
we'll talk about relaxing that
assumption later on.
Okay.
So,
now let's try to
start analyzing this.
So, let's start
as usual in period
2n - 1.
And now, what is the
seller going to accept?
So, when period 2n - 1, the world is
going to end tomorrow,
the buyer makes an offer, what prices
will the seller be willing to accept?
So, they'll accept if and only if the
offered price
P2n - 1
is greater than or equal to what?
Any thoughts?
So, you're the seller. The buyer says,
"I'm going to pay you this amount for
it." You say, "Well, either I can accept
this or I can reject it and get a payoff
of zero."
So, what am I willing to accept? Yeah?
Wouldn't it just be zero? Uh yeah,
anything that's above zero, right?
Exactly zero, we can argue about, but
we'll say if and only if it's greater
than or equal to zero. So, if you offer
me any non-negative price,
my choice is I accept it
or I wait till tomorrow and I get zero.
So, any any positive amount you give me,
I'm willing to accept because it's
better than getting zero tomorrow.
And given that, what is the buyer going
to offer?
So, again, we're working backwards. What
will the buyer offer?
How much will they offer to pay?
It's a good position for the buyer,
right?
They're going to offer to pay zero.
If I know that the seller will accept
any price, I'll I'll offer the smallest
price they'll accept.
Right? What's the story here?
I come to at the end of the day.
Think about I mean, we see this all the
time. It's a store. They have like, you
know, one croissant left. They're about
to close or maybe they have tons of
croissants left.
I know if they don't sell it to me,
they're not going to be able to sell it
to anyone. It'll go stale tomorrow. I
can make a pretty good It's I'm in a
pretty strong bargaining position. I can
say just give it to me for a price of
zero. And we see bakeries have discounts
at the end of the day for exactly this
reason.
Okay, but now let's go to period 2n - 2.
Now, the
buyer is making an offer.
Sorry. Uh
the seller is making an offer. So, the
buyer is choosing whether to accept the
offer or not.
And what offers will the buyer accept?
So, the buyer will accept
if the price PT offered by the seller is
small enough, right?
Any question? Yeah. Is the buyer's value
of the good known to the seller? It is
and that's a crucial assumption. So, uh
it is known and in reality you might
think it wouldn't be known and towards
the end of the course we'll talk about
incomplete information bargaining, but
it becomes becomes really messy. Uh but
yes, V V is known. That's a good point.
And delta is also known.
Uh
so, here we're going to have
say PT star. The buyer will accept if
the price is low enough.
And let's
try to compute what PT star has to be.
So, as usual, PT star is going to be
defined by an indifference condition.
The highest price they'll accept is the
price where if they accept it, they do
just as well as if they were to reject
it and wait until tomorrow.
So,
let's look
at what happens if they were to accept a
price of PT star, then they're going to
get delta to the
2n - 2
of V
minus
PT star.
So, that's if they accept.
What if they reject the offer?
If they reject the offer,
then tomorrow they get to propose
and they're in a great shape. We already
said tomorrow they're going to offer a
price of zero and it's going to be
accepted.
So, that means tomorrow they're going to
get delta to the 2n - 1
times V. Really, it's minus V PT + 1
star.
Uh or I guess I should say here T is
equals 2n - 2, but I'm just writing T
cuz it's a bit cleaner.
And once again, we can see that we can
simplify these discount factors a lot
because we can factor out delta to the
2n - 1 from both terms. And this makes
sense because the question is, do I take
it today or do I wait till tomorrow?
There's really only one discount factor
that matters. It's the discounting
between today and tomorrow. So, we can
equivalently we can cancel things out
and we can say
and just put a delta here.
So, we divide by delta
to the 2n - 2.
So, what we get is
V
and maybe I'll write the general
formula. V minus PT star
equals delta.
So,
in period T,
in an even period where I'm the buyer,
I can either get this utility today or I
can wait till tomorrow and get this
utility where the price I get tomorrow
is going to depend on what we've already
computed for tomorrow using backward
induction.
And if you try to solve for this,
we'll get
PT.
Now, let's ask,
how does this PT star, this threshold
price, compare to PT + 1?
Is it bigger or smaller than PT plus 1?
Well, it's
bigger
because PT is a weighted average of PT
plus 1 and the number V. But we know V
is always bigger than or equal to PT
plus 1.
So that means this is strictly greater
than PT plus 1. And let's try to think
through the intuition for this.
Again, it's about discounting, right?
I'm willing to accept a price that's
higher today than I would get tomorrow
for the classic reason that if I wait
till tomorrow, I have to pay a cost of
delay.
So I'm willing to accept a worse deal
today than I would get tomorrow in order
to avoid the cost of delay. For me, a
worse deal is a higher price because I'm
the buyer.
So I started out with a case of 2n minus
2, but you can see that this formula
actually holds for any even period.
For any even period T the buyer is going
to accept if the price is below a
threshold. The seller is then going to
offer exactly that threshold.
And the threshold
is defined by this formula.
Now let's try to look at odd periods T.
If we're in an odd period T
now it is
the seller who's deciding whether to
accept or reject.
The seller
is going to accept
if PT is greater than or equal to
PT star.
And now can we get a formula for what PT
star is going to be?
It has to say that the seller is
indifferent between selling at a price
of PT star today or waiting until
tomorrow.
If they sell at PT star today
they get PT star
in discounted terms. What happens if
they wait till tomorrow?
Well they get
delta
times PT plus 1 star.
If I wait till tomorrow, we know from
backward induction that the good is
going to be exchanged at a price of PT
plus 1 star, but I have to discount that
by delta and I'm going to be exactly
indifferent if this is if this holds.
So if you want to be
kind of really
mathy about it, we we have a solution,
but it's a bit of a mess.
So what we know
So how do we compute our solution? We
just work backwards.
We know we argued that the
price that's going to be determined in
period 2n minus 1 is exactly zero.
And then we have a sequence of
recursions that allow us to compute what
PT must be if we know PT plus 1.
What PT is if we know PT plus 1 and we
have two different formulas depending on
whether if T is even or odd. So
technically, we could start at the end
and work our way backwards.
Um
then we're going to have some really
messy formulas. It's kind of going to
get ugly, so I'm not going to go through
all the algebra, but I just want to sort
of show you uh
what what we're going to find. So what's
the limit of this uh
of this game?
So we can compute the full strategy, the
outcome
is going to be well, in period zero
the
seller
offers
P0 star
and the buyer accepts.
Where P0 star is determined by starting
at the end and working all the way
backwards.
So once again, we see no delay.
And this already came up earlier. What's
the reason that we have no delay? Why
why do we not see this protracted um
negotiation over the the price that's
going to be paid?
What's kind of missing from the model? I
think someone already brought it up.
Yeah. They have perfect information, so
they can see what happens in time.
Exactly. In reality, when you're
negotiating with a price for someone,
you don't know their value V. You don't
know exactly how much they're willing to
pay. We've made this really stylized
assumption
that everyone knows
the buyer's willingness to pay, exactly
the most the buyer is willing to pay for
this. That would make, say you're
negotiating over a house, it would be
really easy
if you understood exactly how much this
family was willing to pay to buy this
house. In reality, we don't know that
and that's why we see delay. But in this
benchmark model uh with complete
information, we see no delay. I think
this is an example of where an economic
model can be useful even if it gives us
results that are counterintuitive.
Because what it can show us is
it can tell us
demonstrate the importance of certain
features. What this tells us is that
the driver of delay in bargaining is
really incomplete information about
people's preferences.
How do we see this? Well, we see if
there were no incomplete information, we
would have no delay. And this shows us
that something must be missing from the
model and I guess we suspect it's
incomplete information and we can see
that later. We can model that later.
Okay, I want to describe though
briefly
what's the limiting case
if n is very large.
And I explained this is sort of what
we're going to converge to if we looked
at the infinite horizon model.
And it turns out that P0 star
is going to be
1 over
1 plus delta times V.
Let's try to
interpret this. And this is the case, I
should say in our model, the seller
moves first.
What if we had said that the buyer
proposed first?
We can also compute what P0 star is. Any
guesses if the buyer, so we're still
looking at the limit where we could in
principle negotiate for a very long
time.
This is the price that the seller is
going to offer if they propose first.
What if the buyer
got to propose first? Any guesses on
whether this price would be higher or
lower? Again, we can do the algebra, but
I think it's a lot better to kind of
think through
these things intuitively.
Would you rather go first or not in this
negotiation?
My
intuition?
It's not so easy.
Um
it turns out going first is generally
an advantage.
And the reason is that if I go first I
can take advantage of the fact that
yes, we both experience a cost of delay,
but in particular, the other party
experiences a cost of delay and
therefore they must be willing to accept
offers that wouldn't that that aren't
even that good that aren't that good for
them. So if I go first, I can say,
"Look, I'm going to give you a pretty
bad offer and I know you're going to
have to accept it because if you don't
accept it, you're going to have to pay
the cost of delay."
And this gives kind of a first mover
advantage and it turns out what we're
going to get here
is P0 star is going to be delta over 1
plus delta times V.
So if the buyer goes first
the price the buyer is going to get is
going to be strictly smaller by a factor
of delta relative to what the seller
would get if the seller went first.
And here we can see the role of of
discounting, right? What happens if
delta goes to 1?
If delta goes to 1
the price the seller gets if they go
first converges to V over 2.
And the price the buyer gets if they go
first also converges to V over 2.
So we see as delta goes to 1 and the
players become very impatient the first
mover advantage disappears.
Can someone see if they can provide
intuition why does the first mover
advantage disappear
if delta goes to 1? Yeah?
Just to make sure, when delta is 1,
people are very impatient, right? Not
patient. Exactly right.
Okay, so then I mean
if they don't care about waiting longer
to get the first
mover advantage.
Right. If
if we get very very patient, then it
shouldn't really matter who goes first
because tomorrow you get the other
person gets to go first and tomorrow
isn't that much different than today if
delta goes gets very close to 1.
Remember, another interpretation of
delta going to 1, one interpretation is
the players are literally more patient.
Another interpretation is they can make
offers in very rapid succession.
So it could be that the reason period
one is not very discounted relative to
period zero is that the offer made in
period one happens right after the offer
in period zero. They happen in really
quick succession. And intuitively, if
we're making alternating offers every
millisecond, it shouldn't really matter
who goes first. And that's exactly what
we see. The first-mover advantage
disappears.
Let me just to to conclude, try to
derive, give like a heuristic derivation
of these
limiting formulas, and then uh and then
we'll conclude. So, let's
So, how can we try to solve for
let's say the first formula. So, let's
say the seller
proposes.
Then
what we expect
is if the seller proposes
and we're taking the limit
as the number of periods get very large,
then
the difference between period zero and
period two, these we think that that it
should be very very close uh because in
period two, we have like a billion
periods to go, and period zero, we have
like a billion plus two periods to go.
If, you know, since it's a billion, they
they should be pretty similar. Um this
is a heuristic derivation. And now let's
plug this in and see what we can get.
So, we get
P0 star
from this recursion
is equal to 1 minus delta times V
plus delta times P1 star.
But then using
this formula,
we know that P1 star
equals
delta
times P2 star.
Right? I'm just applying
this formula with T equals zero.
And then I'm applying this formula with
T equals one.
Okay?
So, now let's plug this into here.
And we get P0 star
equals 1 minus delta V
plus delta squared
P2 star.
Now, in general, P0 star and P2 star are
going to be different.
But in the limit as N goes to infinity,
P0 and P2 star are going to look really
really similar. And the reason is that,
again, if there's many many periods
ahead of us, a billion periods and a
billion plus two periods, it should be
basically the same. So, let's kind of
squint and make this P0 star.
Now, let's try to solve this.
We bring this to the other side.
So, we get
1 minus delta squared
P0 star
equals 1 minus delta V.
And now there's one kind of trick that I
think is kind of good to remember on
problem sets. It It's not so clear. If
we solve for this,
we get P0 star equals 1 minus delta
over 1 minus delta squared
times V. Uh-oh.
That's not the formula we got.
But it simplifies. Yeah?
We can factor, right? 1 minus delta
squared is just 1 minus delta times 1
plus delta.
The 1 minus deltas cancel, and we
exactly get 1 over 1 plus delta times V.
So, again, I don't want to make the
problem sets or the exams all about
doing algebra, but this is sort of one
trick that I think is is good to know
for this.
Uh let me stop there a little bit early,
but um I think we're good, and uh we'll
continue on Tuesday with uh subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
See you then.